trois
oh non
ma meilleure amie
est une mauvaise chienne
Musique]
est-ce moi suis-je le drame je ne pense pas que
je suis un drame
peut-être que je suis le méchant je ne
pense pas que je suis le méchant
euh combien de fois applaudissent-ils dans la
chanson thème de l'ami oh  euh
cinq
oh
non c'est en fait quatre
quoi non ouais c'est cinq je l'ai entendu
mille fois ouais eh bien non c'est en
fait quatre
c'est cinq
c'est quatre
c'est cinq mais celui qui t'a dit que la vie
allait être comme ça
il n'y a pas de retard ça va être ça  comme
ça c'est cinq
je vais faire ça
comme ça
et puis comme ça
c'est cinq
quatre
tu sais à quoi ça sert
je te l'ai dit
[Musique]